A
VERY DIFFICULT JUGGLING ACT FOR
AUTHORITARIAN GOVERNMENTS LIKE
THE CHINESE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT UKRAINE.
RUSSIA WAS TARGETING THE
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE, TRYING
TO DEPRIVE UKRAINIANS OF HEAT,
WATER, ELECTRICITY, AND OTHER
BRUTAL WINTER APPROACHES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
HOW IS RUSSIA APPROACHING THIS
WINTER?
DO YOU THINK IT'S CRANK UP THE
MISERY, CRANK UP THE SUFFERING,
AND SEE IF THAT HAS ANY KIND OF
EFFECT?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
VERY BIG ISSUE, LIKE WHAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT WITH CHINA,
BUT OF COURSE IN THE CITIES AND
TOWNS ACROSS THE UKRAINE.
THE RUSSIANS UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY THEMSELVES ARE UNDER A LOT
OF PRESSURE, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
NOT GONE VERY WELL IN THIS WAR.
THEY SEE AN OPPORTUNITY, HERE
IS GOING TO BE A LONG, COLD,
DIFFICULT WEATHER FOR THE
UKRAINIANS.
EVEN THOUGH THE UKRAINIANS
MIGHT GALVANIZE BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THAT THEY ARE BEING
OPPRESSED BY THE RUSSIANS,
ATTACKED BY THE RUSSIANS, OUR
COUNTRY COULD GO AWAY IF WE
GIVE UP FIGHTING.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT'S A VERY
STRONG REACTION ON THE SIDE OF
UKRAINE, BUT YOU'VE GOT AN
ELDERLY POPULATION, YOU HAVE A
VERY YOUNG POPULATION, YOU HAVE
KIDS IN HOSPITALS, SOME
CHILDREN WERE BEING KILLED BY
THE ARTILLERY FIRE.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE IN A
DIFFICULT POSITION, BUT THE
RUSSIANS ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
AS I WAS TALKING ABOUT EARLIER,
THE WEST IS ALSO UNDER SOME
PRESSURE.
HOW LONG CAN YOU CONTINUE TO
PUSH ON WITH THE ENERGY ISSUES.
THAT IS WHAT THIS IS RESULTING
IN, DIFFICULT TIMES.
HOW LONG IS THE UNITED STATES
GOING TO CONTINUE THE MASSIVE
SHIPMENT OF WEAPONS THERE?
THEY'RE PLAYING FOR TIME,
PLAYING THE LONG RUN, AND THIS
WINTER IS GOING TO BE A VERY
INTERESTING LONG TERM PROSPECTS
FOR THE RUSSIANS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS LITTLE
PIECE OF VIDEO WHICH I THINK IS
VERY INTERESTING FROM FRIDAY.
IT WAS RUSSIA'S MOTHER'S DAY,
VLADIMIR PUTIN MEETING WITH
MOTHERS OF RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
FIGHTING IN UKRAINE, SEEMING TO
REASSURE THEM THAT SPIRITS
REMAIN HIGH AMONG HIS TROOPS.
THIS IS ALL RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
OF COURSE.
THEY CHERRY-PICK THE MOTHERS
THAT THEY WANT TO HAVE IN THE
ROOM WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN AND SO
ON.
THIS IS DESPITE WIDESPREAD
REPORTS OF RUSSIAN SOLDIERS NOT
HAVING ENOUGH TO EAT, RUSSIAN
MOTHERS LAUNCHING AN ANTI-WAR
PETITION.
HOW TELLING IS THIS PHOTO OP?
IT'S INTERESTING, IT'S PUTIN'S
WAY OF SAYING THAT I HAVE
EVERYTHING UNDER CONTROL, BUT
IT'S REVEALING THAT HE HAS TO
DO THIS.
>> IT IS WORTH ASKING WHY?
WHY NOT SIT DOWN WITH OTHER
MOTHERS?
THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT PUTIN
RECALLS HOW BADLY THIS ENDED IN
THE TENSION WARS THAT HE WAS
INVOLVED IN WHEN HE FIRST CAME
TO POWER.
ABOUT THE CHECHNYA AND THE
AFGHAN WARS, YOU HAVE STRONG
INTERNAL MOVEMENT ON PART OF
THE RUSSIAN MOTHERS OF SOLDIERS
FIGHTING, AND ALSO IN
AFGHANISTAN.
SURPRISINGLY, THESE ORGANIZED
GROUPS THAT WERE NOT FUNDED BY
THE UNITED STATES, OR BY ANY
OTHER FOREIGN GOVERNMENT LIKE
THE RUSSIANS OFTEN ACCUSE THESE
OPPOSITION GROUPS OF BEING,
THESE WERE MOTHERS THAT
ACTUALLY CAUSED REALLY SERIOUS
PROBLEMS IN RUSSIAN SOCIETY FOR
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT, BECAUSE
OF THOSE PREVIOUS WARS,
VLADIMIR PUTIN REMEMBERS THAT
AND DOESN'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN
AGAIN IN UKRAINE.
I THINK HE'S TRYING TO BE
PROACTIVE THERE AND SIT DOWN
AND PROVIDE THESE PHOTO
OPPORTUNITIES, YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IT'S ALL
PROPAGANDA.
THEY ARE CHERRY-PICKED.
BUT IT PLAYS WELL INTERNALLY
INSIDE OF RUSSIA, AND MOTHERS
THAT MIGHT BE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT THEIR KIDS AND SONS
SPECIFICALLY ARE BEING PUT UP
AGAINST IN UKRAINE.
I THINK THAT HE'S TRYING TO
STAY OUT AHEAD OF A PROBLEM
THAT COULD MATERIALIZE FOR HIM
IF HE'S NOT CAREFUL.
>>